the force is what gives a Jedi his path  it's an energy field created by all  living things it surrounds us and  penetrates us it binds the Galaxy  together you refer to the prophecy of  the one who will bring balance to the  force you believe it's this boy before  the dark time a young Jedi named Darth  Vader it was a pupil of mine until he  turned to evil Vader was seduced by the  dark side of the force  verse it will rule the galaxy  a precise hit will start a chain  reaction which should destroy the  station and man your ships and may the  force be with we will then crush the  rebellion with one swift stroke  have you not  you must learn the ways of the force  I'm not afraid you will be you will be  one thing grenades  you must be paid err you don't know the  power of the dark side we will not fight  and you will meet your destiny  I'll have a Jetta  like my father  that boy is our last hope there is major  you